you think i'd be here alone i don't
think so
remember that one scene from home alone
no i'm sorry i meant home alone 2 lost
in new york
excuse me where's the lobby down the
hall and to the left
thanks yeah
that one the one where kevin mcallister
bumps into donald trump in the plaza
hotel lobby
well on wednesday macaulay culkin
responded to a request to remove the
president from the 1992 flick
you guys give up or you're thirsty for
more
after one fan tweeted quote petitioned
to digitally replace trump in home loan
2 with 40 year old macaulay culkin
mack replied simply quote sold
oh come on another fan took it one step
further
and actually edited out trump from the
film all together
showing a young macaulay walking through
the hotel and turning and talking to
well literally no one
excuse me where's the lobby
thanks yeah they even muted trump's
single line so what did mac think of all
that
he responded quote bravo a lovely cheese
pizza
just for me back in november the film's
director christopher columbus revealed
during an interview with insider that
trump's cameo in the film
was at his own request as a requirement
of filming at the plaza
which trump owned at the time quote we
paid the fee but he also said
the only way you can use the plaza is if
i'm in the movie
so we agreed to put him in the movie
excuse me where's the lobby down the
hall and to the left
thanks on wednesday president trump was
impeached for
a second time in his four-year term by
the house of representatives
as a result of inciting violence on
january 6th
when a mob of his followers broke into
the capitol building
now it is up to congress to confront
this egregious
assault on our democracy and after this
we're going to walk down and i'll be
there with you we're going to walk down
we're going to walk down anyone you want
but i think right here we're going to
walk down
to the capitol the incident resulted in
five deaths
including the death of a capital police
officer
and we're going to cheer on our brave
senators and congressmen and women
and we're probably not going to be
cheering so much for
some of them because you'll never
take back our country with weakness you
have to show strength and you have to be
strong
[Music]